By the way let me help you guys
understand something because sometimes
people don't. The Gazelle intensity where
you're on beans and rice rice and beans,
where you do not have a life, you do not
go on vacation, you do not do anything. Is until you get out of debt and you finish
baby step 3. When you have your emergency
fund in place and your debt free except
your home that's when you lighten up a
notch. You let the foot off the gas a
little bit and you start to live.
That's when you save up and go on a
vacation or you save up and pay for a
couch or you save up and move up and
home or you save up and pay cash for a
little better car because you're driving
a hoopty or whatever and hopefully you
can do that while you're saving fifteen
percent towards retirement, if you can't
then you knock a couple of those little
things out to get your lifestyle back up
to a reasonable level and then you
then you start baby steps four because
baby step four, five and six (which is
fifteen percent of your income going
into retirement and baby step 5
is kids college and six is paying off
your home early) those are done you know
over a period of years, you know. And it's
part of your overall goal. So here's the
thing I read this thing somebody tweeted
me earlier today. It's lady said I quit
doing Dave Ramsey so I could save my
marriage. And when I read the article it
was like you know she was till gazelle
intense and trying to pay off her house
and her husband hated her and
hated me and everything else because they were
still, you know, they're still just living
on beans and rice five, six, seven years
later. And that is not what we teach and
so you can't say you quit doing Dave
Ramsey because honey you weren't doing
Dave Ramsey. You weren't doing what we
teach. And you did what you wanted to do
and you blame me for it but that's not
what we teach. We don't teach people to
do that and nor would I teach you to do
something to end your marriage, that's
just absolutely drama queen stuff. You've
never heard that here on the air. I tell
people to do things
keep their marriage together.
If you go into hyper drama mode
for a decade like that and your spouse
is not on board, that's not me giving
your marriage problems, that's you giving
you marriage problems. You know that's
not what we teach. So baby steps 1, 2 &
3 are with great focused intensity
extreme levels of sacrifice and even
then your spouse needs to be on board
because it's not going to work you're
just going to make everybody mad around
when you try to force this stuff upon
them but when it is a shared goal we're
sacrificing to win. We're going to live
like no one else so later we can live
and give like no one else. Then when you
break through baby step 3, you have your
emergency fund in place, you don't have
any payments but a house payment that
puts you in a place to be able to save
and invest and be able to do some
lifestyle things and be able to increase
your giving and get yourself in a rhythm
that is much more reasonable long-term.
And still be able to hit the goals. It
still happens and you still have to be
focused, you still have to be a grown-up but
I'm amazed the number of things I get
blamed for that I didn't do. This is The
Dave Ramsey Show. Hey guys thanks for
watching if you enjoyed this video click
the subscribe button to get the latest
content and check out these other great
clips from the show!